let's see if we can evaluate the
indefinite integral of tangent X DX and
so like always pause the video and see
if you can figure it out on your own and
I will give you a hint think reverse
chain rule alright so you have attempted
it it's a reverse chain rule that's kind
of you're seeing a function you think
it's derivative and you can integrate
with respect to that function all you
see here or is a tangent of X what am I
talking about
well whenever you see a tangent of X or
a cosecant or a secant at least in my
brain I always like to break it down
into how its defined in terms of sine
and cosine because we do at least have
some tools and I at our disposal for
dealing with sines and cosines or at
least our brains at least my brain has
an easier time processing them but we
know tangent of X is the same thing as
sine of X over cosine of X so let me
rewrite it that way so this is equal to
this is equal to the indefinite integral
of sine of X over cosine of X DX and you
could even write it this way and this is
a little bit of a hint you could even
write it as you could even write it as
sine of X times 1 over cosine of X so if
you couldn't figure it out the first
time I encourage you to pause the video
again and once again think reverse chain
reverse chain rule so what am I talking
about when I keep saying reverse chain
rule so let's let's just review that
before I before I proceed with this
example because if I were to just tell
you well what's the indefinite integral
of 1 over X DX well we know that that's
going to be the natural log of the
absolute value of X plus C now if I were
to totally ask you what is the
indefinite integral of f prime of x
times 1 over f of X DX what is that
going to be well here's where the
reverse chain rule applies where I have
1 over f of X Y I would like if only I
had its derivative being multiplied by
this thing that I could just integrate
with respect to f of X well I do I have
its derivative right over here I felt
applying times this thing so I could use
the reverse chain rule to say that this
is going to be equal
to the natural log of the absolute value
of the thing that I have in the
denominator which is f of X plus C and
that is exactly that is on made it to
whites you can't see everything but
that's exactly what's going on right
over here I have if I say that this
thing right over here if cosine of X is
f of X then sine of X is not quite the
derivative it's the negative of the
derivative so f prime of X would be
negative sine of X so how do i how do I
get that how do i engineer it well what
if I just throw a negative there and a
negative there so it's essentially
multiplying by negative 1 twice which is
still going to stay positive
so now negative sine of X right over
here I'm trying to squeeze it in between
the integral sign and the sine of X this
right over here now that I put a
negative sine of X that is the
derivative of cosine of X so this is f
prime F prime of X so I can just apply
the reverse chain rule this is going to
be we deserve a little mini drumroll
here this is going to be equal to the
natural log of the absolute value of our
f of X which is going to be cosine of X
and then of course we have our plus C
and we can't forget we can't forget we
had this little negative sitting out
here so we're going to have to put the
negative right over there and we are
done we just figured out that's kind of
a neat result because it feels like
that's something that we should know how
to take the indefinite integral of the
indefinite integral of tangent of X is
and it's neat that these are connected
in this way is the negative natural log
of the absolute value of cosine of X
plus C